Looking back we were really lucky because
one of the early mountain bikers was a woman named
Wende Cragg.
Right at the same time as she got into
mountain biking
she also got into photography and she would go out riding
almost everyday.
so she would bring her camera with her
on these rides and
take tons and tons of pictures and so
she created
a really impressive archived of early
mountain biking
the photos in their own right
are really
fascinating and they allow us to tell and
really understand the history better.
I mean the photographs have been crucial
at times at correcting our
understanding
the memories that people recall.
It's hard for people to remember some
time exactly what year would take
something happened
but then they can look back at the
images and say okay like we can see that
in this girl he didn't you had part
X not part Y on your bike and so we know
that this is when this innovation
happened.